so I was raised in a bit of a
conservative family where women
shouldn't be climbing and traveling on
their own so coming to Dubai really
helped me find all these scores that I
enjoyed the way you have to reconnect to
nature to mother earth to feel better
about yourself my name is Mark Beaumont
and I'm an endurance athlete with the
current world record for cycling around
the planet seeking adventures and
finding stories is why I'm most
passionate about
ever since I can remember I've had that
sense of curiosity about the world this
time I've come to do back
here a meeting leader to hear how her
love of the outdoors and adventure
sports has hugely helped her both
physically and mentally
[Music]
what have you got planned what do you
think we can get up to in the next so
I'm gonna take your wakeboarding and
we're gonna go to Hutta we're gonna
kayak in a dam and we're gonna hike a
little bit and maybe come and is that
still in the desert or is that a
completely different terrain it's a
computer in amazing be careful
it's not often I try something that I
have never done before
baby wakeboarding is not begging in
Scotland maybe canoes to code so mark
when the boat starts moving you feel it
and you just live with it and then you
just look at the boat and enjoy I've
always been active in Dubai but then I
had an incident where I fractured my hip
and I couldn't do anything for a year
and this was the turning point for me
this is what made me become a more
adventurous person I thought that I have
to try everything I couldn't do in that
year and this is where my journey
started
[Music]
pretty amazing place we go wait whirring
for the first time while backdrop
[Music]
the natural
that's incredible my arms
I really think that being healthy
physically is very important but I
really focus on being healthy mentally
more anytime I feel down or I feel super
anxious I just packed my bags and travel
to the mountains or go camping or just
be in the outdoors and reconnect with
myself as someone who suffers from
anxiety being outdoors and being active
helped me so much and it still does I
mean you feel like you're a million
miles from Dubai here I know skyscrapers
the mountains two natural skyscrapers I
think what sports given you know is the
fact that you're not worrying about
tomorrow you're not thinking too much
about the past
you're absolutely stuck in that moment
she's slight passion about sharing that
journey
[Music]
[Music]
I get started pretty quickly nice and
this looks tiny from the valley floor
look at it top of the world
nice beautiful
adventure sports and finding them as
ultimately you know from our time
together that's kind of created your
identity it's kind of who you are I know
that my aim is to get more and more
people in the outdoors like this is
something I want to do being active and
being closer to nature
will make you a better person mentally
and physically I've absolutely loved
this and you know what the coolest part
you know you've been so honest about
your journey you know what's what all
these adventures are done for you so
thank you and I hope we can do smile
it's my pleasure
you
you